willkommen zur heutigen sitzung heute
wollen wir uns mit diesem netten herren
hiermit dieser schicken weißen fliege
befassen
das ist peter dann in welden und ich hab
ich werde ihn jetzt demnächst noch
schreiben das er bitte auch für den
workshop für den sich einige von ihnen
angemeldet haben
auch diese schöne weiße fliege wieder
anlegt kann ich nicht versprechen aber
wir versuchen es und peter van weegen
hat ein aufsatz geschrieben über den
mystery of metaphysiker freedom
der ist schon ein bisschen älter aber
dieser aufsatz motto kennst ihn viel
besser als ich diese aufsatz enthält
jedenfalls die wichtigsten grundgedanken
könnte man sagen dass seiner philosophie
der freiheit und wir haben uns das jetzt
vorgestellt der firma grad fragen wer
bei dem workshop dabei ist von ihnen
einfach wer sich angemeldet hatte ein
paar okay gut genau also wir werden
diese sitzung heute dazu nutzen um uns
vorzubereiten auf sein denken generell
sein ding der freiheit generell das
heißt die fragen die wir heute
diskutieren die es ihnen heute kommen
die können wir dann auch während des
workshops stellen
wir können uns immer wieder auf diesen
aufsatz beziehen du meintest vor hin
dass eine art grundtext wo so ganz
allgemein sein anliegen dargelegt wird
jetzt nicht in jedem logischen detail
sie finden hier zum beispiel keine in
diesem text jedenfalls habe ich nicht
gesehen welche logische formalisierung
die bringt da gar nicht das ist also für
uns in bachelor studierende für sie
bachelor studierende besonders gut
geeignet ok hast du noch ein bisschen
was zu diesem text generell zu sagen
also versuchen aus dass er in der lage
ist seine argumente zu formulieren ruhte
sich irgendwie hinter mathematischen
symbol zu verstecken backens definitiv
ein guter analytischer philosoph in
diesen sind also was für hippie versucht
es auf engem raum seine position zum
problem das daher zu schultern also die
position wieder
in diesem anderen paper ausgeteilt haben
indische position bisher ist das ist so
ein begriff ist langsam
diese position die man systems
nachdenklich und peter mallin waren
vertreten
die aber definitiv auch also also mit
funktions die schon ihre berechtigung
hat heute diskutieren
und wir haben ja schon ein paar fragen
ihnen mitgeteilt im voraus und die das
ist die quelle noch mal die
literaturangaben und die fragen lauten
also folgendermaßen was versteht von ihm
wegen der metaphysischer freiheit das
ist ein begriff den er hier ins spiel
bringt was versteht er unter einem
negativen begriff der freiheit was das
was im gegensatz dazu eine von einem
positiven wir sind auf diese begriffe
negativ und positive freiheit bereits in
der ersten sitzung zu sprechen gekommen
auch in der zusammenfassung haben wir
das schon geklärt dann aber ganz
spannend was versteht man ihn wegen
unter können kennen weil seinen vortrag
auf der tagung wird sich auch mit ort
und kann mit sollen und können befassen
also können ist so das entscheidende
wort wenn es um metaphysische freiheit
geht das ist so dass das zentrale wort
und das dreht sich alles
am abend hatten will hat findet das wort
und bleibt das bezieht sich auf eine
prothese die eben kann schon vertreten
hat dass sein können
also wenn ich meinem sohn sagt er soll
gefälligst ein zimmer aufbauen und dann
impliziert ist halt auch mal von ihrem
wagen dass er sein zimmer aufräumen kann
und diese diese irgendwie unscheinbare
these haken hat den ganz zentrale rolle
in bestimmten argumenten für den fahrer
darauf wenn es noch zu sprechen kommen
also das ist ein aspekt seiner theorie
der in diesem aufsatz ein bisschen kurz
kommt ich werde die lücke füllen damit
sie auch das nötige hintergrundwissen
für die nächsten wochen genau und dann
noch die letzte frage die ist vielleicht
die wichtigste inwiefern metaphysische
freiheit also dieses können oder auch
anders können mit dem der position des
determinismus und der des in
determinismus kompatibel ist weil es ist
ja nicht nur so dass von wegen sagen
wird sie ist nicht mit dem b-team ismus
kompatibel sagt auch sie ist nicht mit
dem in determinismus kompatibel also das
ist so sein dilemma könnte man sagen es
ist nicht mit dem determinismus
vertretbar verträglich auch nicht mit
milde termin is muss aber dennoch müssen
wir sie annehmen oder wir haben die
intuition oder was auch immer
und deswegen folgt daraus die position
des mysterien ismus dass es halt nur
unerklärlich ist das ist so die die die
grundproblematik und die ist auch sehr
einleuchtend die ist da braucht man gar
nicht so große logische überlegung jetzt
anstellen das ist prima zimmer sehr
intuitiv erst aber muss wird intuition
aufpassen weil wir hatten gesehen der
letzten sitzung prinzip der alternativen
möglichkeiten bei harry frankfurt sagt
er es falsch ja es gibt fälle die wir
konstruieren können die wir auch in der
zusammenfassung ihn noch mal geschickt
haben dass wir eben über der terminiert
sind das also wenn wir uns gegen eine
option entscheiden
das dann auch diese option nicht
existieren würde unabhängig von uns und
das also die fehlende option nicht der
grund unseres handelns ist sondern
unsere entscheidung die sich eben mit
der faktischen lage dann
zufälligerweise oder auch nicht oder
bewusster weise deckt und deswegen muss
man da immer ein bisschen misstrauisch
sein wenn man sich dass es eben in
solchen großen fragen zu sehr auf
intuition verlässt also philosophie
beginnt meistens dann erst richtig
spannend zu werden wenn wir unsere
intuition in anfangen zu konfigurieren
wenn es den konflikt von intuition
einerseits ist es wertvoll zu lassen wir
setzen darauf
sie haben sich für das und breites kann
irgendwie nicht und da begeben den
ersten ganz großen problem und deswegen
sind die intuitionen nicht einfach wenn
man von philosophie sind schon ein
wichtiger kompass aber ist eben nicht
der einzige kommt was auf die uns
verlassen können
dann beginnt erst die richtige
philosophischer genau und du hast
stichwort gegeben philosophische arbeit
die beginnt jetzt mit dem ersten zitat
ist ihnen hier wir werden dieses zitat
wird jetzt die frage aufgeworfen nachdem
nach der freiheit generell also wir
könnten uns jetzt mal fragen hier nach
dem diesen begriff ihr das ist sozusagen
der begriff der im negativen freiheit
den bringt er hier
negativ konzept und er sagt ebenso viele
arten wie es negative freiheit gibt so
viele arten von freiheit gibt es also es
ist so eine sehr vielseitige rede von
freiheit wie könnte man jetzt noch mal
diese negative freiheit bestimmen haben
sie noch mal ein beispiel jetzt
unabhängig von seinen beispielen was
negative freiheit ist und wo und
vielleicht auch das problem von
negativer freiheit steht schreibt auch
noch mal hin negative verehrt oder sagt
ein negativer begriff von freiheit
schaut mal negative freiheit
mehrere beispiele und wir haben alle
etwas gemeinsam was er gewinnt es
sie das nochmal teilnehmen wollten
ja
meine reaktion also meinetwegen beispiel
ich bin aber ein studium hier ein event
ist oder gekocht und weiß was in diesem
moment nicht
heute gelten
ich glaube
also jedenfalls nicht handlungsweise
also was ich so ein bisschen bei hier in
dieser diskussion vermisst habe war es
ein bisschen die unterscheidung zwischen
willensfreiheit und handlungsfreiheit er
wird wahrscheinlich haben
willensfreiheit mit diesen können in
verbindung bringen
vermutlich jetzt aber das habe ich hier
so ein bisschen vermisst er spricht doch
eigentlich nur von negativer freiheit
und scheint scheint das dann mit dieser
handlungsfreiheit in verbindung zu
bringen also eher oder wie siehst du es
nicht genau das müssen wir uns mal
notieren willensfreiheit und
handlungsfreiheit
warum bringt ja die unterscheidung jetzt
nicht hier zugleich mit ins spiel oder
ich mache mal hier so einfalls und frage
vielleicht ist diese unterscheidung
nicht oder bei könnte ihn fragen wie wie
er willens verhält definiert also er
wird wahrscheinlich sagen über können
oder metaphysische freiheiten so aber ja
also es gibt ja eben diesem 9
also da habt ihr dafür dass uns den weg
frei
das führt zu verwirrung führen sollte
das anders verwenden dann natürlich
nicht mehr klarheit das komplette dieses
um den koffer das überhaupt einander
widersprechende froh wenn ich den
begriff das verstehe ich ja eine
daumenbreite spots determinismus vereine
und der danach bereitete sich mit der
terrorismus und vereinfachen kommen aber
sie unter freiheit das gar nicht alles
verstehen dann ist gar nicht klar
das kompakte gewisse und inkompetent
listen erhöht das ist einer der gründe
warum dann also das ist ein ganz neuer
aus und deswegen plädiere auf diesen
begriff völlig aus dem motto wer
schreibt einen aufsatz in dem er
dieses problem werde es dort zu benutzen
werden
also ich meine auch jetzt hier diese
diese platz an platzangst roddick 4 und
open spaces ist die frage wie ist es
eine einschränkung unserer
handlungsfreiheit also ich bin deutlich
nicht frei etwas zu tun
die frage ist halt ob solche
neurotischen zustände
ob die mit auch unsere willensfreiheit
tangieren das jetzt eben zum einen meine
frage ist eben wie hängt negative
freiheit mit willensfreiheit und mit
handlungsfreiheit zusammen ja also auf
den ersten blick liest sich das für mich
wie so eine handlungsfreiheit
aber die frage ist könnte nicht in
diesem fall von platzangst auch unsere
willensfreiheit betroffen sein
ja innere oder äußere einschränkung das
ist die frage
[Musik]
genau und nach innerlichkeit hat was
innerlichkeit haben ja gesehen hat immer
was mit wird er mit dem willen zu tun
als äußerlichkeit also dieses lebens
beispiel ist klar ist eine äußere sache
ihr naja ist die frage auf wie das
beispiel der pistole
da kommt dann einfach jemand von außen
und und schränkt uns ein von außen oder
mal wir werden gefesselt dass es das
beste beispiel werden gefesselt ja
können wir innerlich noch so viel wollen
wir wollen aufstehen wir wollen
irgendwas machen wohin gehen und es geht
nicht wir sind von außen eingeschränkt
aber wie ist es wenn mir eben innerlich
eingeschränkt ist oder sind oder wenn
diesen fall haben dass unser wille in
sich gespalten ist oder so partner durch
die entgegengesetzte interessen und wir
können nicht von einer ebene zweiter
stufe dann entscheiden was es also das
ist vielleicht ein bisschen noch offen
er spricht ja nur von diesem negativen
begriff finde ich auch interessante
these hier der many cars of freedom
bekommt der amerikanisch of constraints
als es so viele arten die wir zwänge
kennen so viele arten von freiheit von
zwängen müsste man natürlich finden
es ist irgendwann wahrscheinlich sogar
mehrere freiheit die der in abwesenheit
von immer so eine einschränkungen oder
zwänge und dann vielleicht äußere
freiheit also man kann damit glaube ich
noch viel machen
der versucht es er selbst zu beschreiben
schwerpunkt auf den eher dahin aus wenn
das so sagen dass das noch nicht dass es
was uns oder dass es da einen anderen
begriff anwalt der wichtig ist und er
nicht einfach mal fall von natürlich
sind es sagen der wichtigsten politisch
weit zu sein
freie meinungsäußerung zu berichten oder
frei zu sein bestimmte ängste aber wir
machen einfach mal weiter da haben sie
noch eine bemerkung zu diesem zitat was
diesen negativen begriff anbelangt also
meine frage ist dann immer eben die nach
willens verhandlungsfreiheit weil ich
das eben
ich tendiere dazu eben negative freiheit
mit handlungsfreiheit zu identifizieren
und es halt die frage liefern man dieses
konzept auch auf willensfreiheit
beziehen kann
das wäre meine frage jetzt wie verhält
sich negative freiheit das bezogen auf
negative freiheit erst mal schauen ob
ich noch ein bisschen stift papier und
können wir mal uns mit dem zweiten
textabschnitt fassen aber seine frage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein guter punkt weil er hier ja gar
nicht so sehr glaube ich eine von einem
positiv konzept spricht oder ich habe es
jedenfalls nicht
jetzt gesehen spricht entweder von
diesem negativen negativen begriff oder
von dem metaphysischen begriff oder also
von den positiven spricht der ja
letztendlich gar nicht nett ist ein
guter punkt also die wie verhält sich
das zu dem positiven begriff von
freiheit weil es gibt ja diese ganz
bekannte unterscheidung von negativer
positive freiheit die wir bei immanuel
kant schon finden freiheit einen
positiven verständnis sagt den positiven
verstande und im negativen verstanden
und wieso spricht er jetzt hier nicht
von positiven
[Musik]
klingt also beispiel die heiligung das
schon sehr ähnlich ist wie das was man
eine position halten assoziieren würde
deswegen ja auch die frage gut und jetzt
kommt der große übergang als er sagt
jetzt offensichtlich hier diese diese
negativer begriff von freiheit der ist
in politischen und psychologischen
situation relevant politik wirtschaft
psychologie und damit habe ich so ein
bisschen problem mit der psychologie
weil das die psychologie also die innere
angelegenheit die hängt ja immer auch
mehr mit der willensfreiheit zusammen
also solche begriffe wie wille und
entitäten gewinne sind gehören zur
psychologie eigentlich zu oder auch
seelische aktivitäten das ist ja der
punkt danke die die rationale danke die
rationale psychologe rationale
psychologie in der metaphysik betrachtet
ja auch immer die seele und so weiter
und gut die frage ist wo ist freiheit
jetzt anzusiedeln generell aber ich habe
zu den eindruck hier kommen auch ganz
stark positive konzepte von freiheit mit
ins spiel wenn es um die willensfreiheit
geht wie auch immer als er aber politik
ist klar wenn wir eben von einem
politischen system gehindert werden
etwas zu tun wenn wir zu wenig geld
haben um was uns zu kaufen oder
irgendwie unsere wünsche zu realisieren
dann ist das eine einschränkung unserer
handlungsfreiheit
diese unterstellung nicht genau
genau heute leicht in abwesenheit von
einschränkungen ist wahrscheinlich
wieder hinreichend behandlungs reiten
auf lebenszeit
ja das ist eine spannende frage also in
beiden fällen müssen wir auch noch
positive etwas punkten also entweder tun
können was wir hören oder wollen können
das wir wollten und da kommt dann immer
sein positives element ist was hier
beschreibt es noch mal etwas ist nur die
negative vielleicht notwendig ist für
handlungsraum aber nicht schon
hinreichend europe wenn kein hindernis
da ist heißt es noch nicht das tun kann
was ich will weiß vielleicht fehlt mir
diese fähigkeit dazu aber man könnte
jetzt sagen wenn ich in mir irgendwie
einen trieb in mir finde der gar nicht
willens frei ist dann werde ich eben
handlungs flaschen drin also in diesem
sommer also wenn ich eben selbst wenn
ich dir terminiert wäre und so aber wir
sind guter punkt dass man das vielleicht
nicht zu sehr zu eng aufeinander bezieht
negative freiheit mit handlungsfreiheit
und positive freiheit mit
willensfreiheit dass man das ein
bisschen noch mal auseinander
sie haben recht zu geben ein zitat
deswegen auch videos aufgenommen hatten
die folie wo er ja so eine formulierung
verwendet wie sehr die richtung geht von
handlungsweisen das trinkt sich eben auf
so ein bisschen also diese beispiele die
ihr gegeben hat er jetzt in dem erst in
dem ersten zitat das schien mir alles
mit ausnahme vielleicht dieser
neurotischen platzangst solche form von
also unterbunden handlungsfreiheit
handlungsfähig zu sein ja genau und ich
glaube das würde ich ihn auch noch gerne
fragen also ich würde ihn gerne fragen
ob es so was wie innere handlungen gibt
also ob handlungsfreiheit ob
willensfreiheit sich re formulieren
lässt in einer bestimmten form von
innerer handlungsfreiheit
diese frage habe ich schon ganz lange
wieder also zb so eine willensbildung
wenn sie mein herr frank verdenken
das sagt dann muss irgendwie eine
harmonie hergestellt werden das so oder
so volition zweiter stufe und erster und
so das ist das nicht auch eine aktivität
ist ja auch nicht eine handlung im spiel
oder sona mitbekommt
der äußerlich eine äußerliche körper
bewegung oder so aber prinzipiell bin
ich geneigt die opposition zustimmen
dass und punkte
wenn du recht recht ist sollte man auch
daraus die konsequenzen daraus die
konsequenz ziehen dass diese
unterscheidung zwischen willensfreiheit
und handlungsweise eigentlich eher
problematisch ist und man sehe er nicht
dass sich geben sollte dass man und er
macht es ja nicht geht ja nicht so sehr
genau das wenn er sagt es ist nicht so
sehr die unterscheidung zwischen zwei
arten von unterschiedlicher freiheit wir
uns fort und handlungsfreiheit ist es
geht um handlungen die reflektierter und
weniger reflektiert das sein können also
so würde das jetzt sagen es geht um die
selben entitäten handlung und es geht es
ihr mottos der handlung also wie die
handlung ausgeführt wird ist es eine
innere handlung ist eine äußere handlung
und nicht so sehr um zwei arten von
handlung also ihre mode der handlung
oder oder reflexive ausprägungen von
handlungen also das ist der riesen
debatte handlungsfeld und willens weil
wie man willensfreiheit wirklich
definieren soll das ist
handlungsfreiheit ist einfacher
irgendwie tendenziös aber wenn man dann
eben sagt es gibt auch innere handlungen
und da habe ich noch keine richtige
antwort drauf weil manche philosophen
sprechen von einer inneren handlungen
zum beispiel david hume spricht von
inneren actions und auch immanuel kant
spricht von einer inneren handlung man
damals suchten sein werden so das ist
eine frage die ich schon länger mit mir
herumtragen und die bei dieser
gelegenheit gerne auch loswerden würde
aber jetzt sagt er hier eben jetzt gibt
es im gegensatz dazu noch die
metaphysische freiheit und die
diskussionen über metaphysische freiheit
verwenden wörter wie gut freiheit frei
und auf freie weise dieses freely die
eben schwer verständlich sind wenn wir
nur ein negatives an negativen begriff
haben also
wir reden in verschiedenen hinsichten
von frei aber wir müssen schauen ob wir
auch so von frei sprechen können dass es
nicht nur im sinne von frei von ist
folglich verschiedenen problemen immer
schon diskutiert wurde das war das
problem dass die freiheit und glück ist
von harrison miteinander vereinbar sein
können oder die freiheit und
determinismus miteinander vereinbar sein
können und so weiter und so fort
und wer sagt denn dass die debatte
kampfstoffe mehr davon und lesen wieder
der begriff reid verwendet wird also
irgendwie scheine dies oder das war
hätten mehr ist es immer abwinken und
damit dann begründet er dessen vermögen
das wege sagt er also in diesem
metaphysischen debatten haben wir
vermuten kurzer annahme dass in diesen
mit der physischen in baden der berühmte
fall anders
wie eingangs geschildert jetzt müssen
uns natürlich noch überlegen was denn so
eine metaphysische debatte eigentlich
ist das hat er jetzt ja noch nicht hier
so richtig gebracht
also hier kommt jetzt ganz klar so ein
glaube das ist so ein metaphysisches
problem wenn es eben um determination
geben
hier kann es sinnvoll sein die terminals
also wenn solche fragen wie freier wille
kommen ins spiel kommen dann geht es
hier noch mehr um metaphysik oder wo
siehst du die metaphysik jetzt ins spiel
kommen in dieser debatte alternative
möglichkeiten
wir schauen mal hier klassische
unterscheidung zwischen generell und
speziell der generellen mitte stellen so
die frage nach den allgemeinen baustein
in unserer wirklichkeit was existieren
was gibt s oder das ist überhaupt
existenz und dann gibt es spezielle
metaphysik und die stellt keine
spezielle fragen gibt es gott haben wir
einen freien willen sind wie unsterblich
so ein bisschen hennig ist es ja dann
auch bekannten noch so
insofern also die frage nach dem brand
film ist traditionellerweise
also es geht um metaphysische probleme
was ist ein metaphysisches problem was
würdest du sagen ganz
also nächste nächste frage hier für die
frage was ist metaphysik überhaupt weil
das wird ja auch allzu häufig so
selbstverständlich verwendete begriffe
was versteht ja einig und metaphysik
das wird richtig was ein philosophisches
nicht immer so ganz klar als die von
herzen alles hängt zusammen mit der
frage zeigt sich da durchaus sehr
generell sind dass sie mit einem
besonderen wahrheitsanspruch auf
einhergeht
anders als zum beispiel eben jenen
bereichen der naturwissenschaften und
der weise bewusst mehr darum geht eine
elegante empirisch adäquate erklärung am
stück scheint sie mit der musik wirklich
so eigentlich pedantisch der
wissenschaft also ergibt also das ist
eine weitere frage wie wie verhält sich
das mit der metaphysik
die gretchenfrage wie hältst du es mit
der metaphysik mit der theologie
die these dass metaphysik möglich ist es
gibt also wie die berühmte frage im
anschluss entfernte mit der physik und
metaphysik als wissenschaft möglich und
nicht nur kennt auch andere regeln wie
zum beispiel den logischen positivsten
haben wir hier den metaphysiker screen
angegriffen
daneben lag genau jetzt war da noch eine
meldung ganz hinten
sie geben
es war eine warnung auslösen
keine fertigen kleine beispiele haben
der personaler einfach etwas
[Musik]
ein bisschen motivieren und da sehen wir
also über könnte jetzt schon vorweg
greifen
eine frage hier rechts im eck notieren
ist freiheit ein postulat nach kant kann
sagt dass wir auch das ist eine idee
notwendig idee der vernunft nach kant
wobei nach kann sie ja nicht nur die
idee ist dann ja wirklich wird die einen
die einzige der ideen diese metapher
rationalen psychologie also seele ist ja
auch noch seine ideen die aber nicht
unlogisch oder faktisch erkennbar ist
oder wirklich wert und freiheit ist
verkannt faktisch jetzt könnte man sich
fragen also so mit kant ist freiheit
eine idee unserer vernunft weil er sagt
er wir können es nicht beweisen muss
endlich ne also postulat charakter so na
also freiheit als idee
und das soll stellung wenn ich dich
unterbricht das sollen ist ja nach kant
faktisch also das soll ist bei kant
immer moralisch zu verstehen also du
sollst der kategorische imperativ
willkommen da noch drauf und kann
spricht von dem faktum der vernunft sagt
also es ist faktisch so ist eine
tatsache dass wir in uns moralische
gebote vernehmen und sagte also
argumentiert dafür dass also er bringt
beispiele form von film geworden und so
weiter und er sagt es ist also es ist
einfach eine tatsache ich glaube jetzt
ist effekt dass jemand dafür
verantwortlich ist dass diese völkermord
begangen wurden
und ich finde es ist eine tatsache dass
diese menschen ist nicht hätten machen
sollen sich näherten und was er dann
eben nächste woche vertreten wird die
citizens wollen können also wenn sie es
nicht hätten tun sollen dass sie getan
haben hätten sie auch diesen völkermord
nicht
es ist wie in der grund letztlich zu
sagen es ist ein guter punkt wir müssen
nach dem status des sollens fragen ist
es sollen ein moralisches konzept oder
ist es ein ja was ist das eigentlich
sollen können
was ist es sollen ist das sollen
moralisch und woher kommt die moralische
verbindlichkeit
das soll uns bitteschön wir können doch
sagen es gibt keine moralischen gebote
sind alles konstrukte das sagen ganz
viele denker der vergangenheit nie
gesagt dass oder der marke saab sagt er
sagt es gibt völker kannibalismus total
okay ja und so also da muss natürlich
von ihnen wegen dann eigentlich auch
wenn er sagt es gibt einen sonnen und
davon einiges ableitet nämlich wenn es
einen solchen gibt dann gibt es auch ein
können muss er eigentlich fragen gibt es
überhaupt und sollen
den kleinen satz wurde es ein
kräftemessen beispiel um seinen 100
punkte marke
deswegen ob wir das aufgenommen haben da
sagt da es gibt ja auch andere es wird
ja alles möge hier der philosophie in
frage gestellt also dass wir ein produkt
also um ein bewusstsein haben oder das
ist eben dann ist er auch noch ein
mysterium ist bezüglich der moral
vielleicht sogar das also nicht nur der
freiheit dass er sagt wir müssen uns als
freie denken schon impliziert dieser
mysterien is muss nicht auch ein
mysterium ismus der moral wir müssen die
welt so denken als ob es objektive
moralisches gebot genauso würde sagen
könne nicht anders denkt aber vielleicht
im unterschied zur freiheit für das ist
nicht zu widersprechen
also dass das team sind hier mysteriöse
an der freiheit ist das ist uns diese
idee egal mit anders irgendwie nicht
abstreifen können nicht so serie okay
okay dann die hat nicht zu diesen antino
mission charakter das ist richtig aber
wir sollten jedenfalls bei dem soll ein
bisschen machen
[Musik]
auch so was wie normativität dessen sich
ein wieder riesentopf normativität woher
kommt sie als es sollen normativ
natürlich jetzt sehr sehr weiterführende
fragen aber vielleicht kommen wir darauf
zu sprechen
so und jetzt gehen wir noch mal zurück
zu diesem zitat otto waren hier noch
fragen dazu hier
juli
[Musik]
in diesem sinn
unterwegs
also ich glaube von ihnen wegen
interessiert sich eben nicht so sehr für
das die art des sollens ich glaube er
würde sagen es gibt einfach sollen
dieses wir haben stark intuitionen
abgespalten nächste woche das ist so
eine kleine lücke hier bis jetzt hat er
auch die mit erfunden so vielen nächste
woche da kümmern wir sind gespannt sein
also ich weiß nicht wie weit dann darauf
auch den säulen zu begriff eingehen wird
oder nicht
das stellen wir dann sehen aber bis
jetzt recht dass das sowohl seite war
ihm bis jetzt noch nicht so interessiert
hat war nachdem er die frage eben immer
mehr die frage interessiert hat ob es
eben gehören können gifte in bestimmten
situationen und was genau bedeuten würde
da gibt es eben auch ein ganz neuer
stationär heißt politik dann versucht ja
gut vermögen hagener personifizieren
in welchem sinn genau von können die
rede ist in die
in diesen debatten was daran was er
nicht wirklich tut also hier sagt er nur
oder was er sagt also können wir nicht
so verstehen im sinne von moralischen
und möglichkeiten und wie soll man keine
mehr sind verstehen sind von ist die svs
ergibt so die valente formulierung du
bringst mich darauf einen weiteren guten
oder glaube ich auch eine wichtige frage
nämlich pille die ist ja auch so was wie
ja ist ja eigentlich eine substanz wie
rung oder so eine art von entität auch
also die frage ist es ein modus ist das
moderne modalität möglichkeit dass jetzt
schwach das ist jetzt logisch oder
metaphysischen schwachen sind oder ist
bielecki nicht auch so was wie kaka city
oder sowas wie so ein vermögen die eine
person hat ich habe das vermögen in mir
wie bei aristoteles die dynamik und was
sagte dazu also mit der füße steigen
genommen also von innen wagen verfolgt
eine sehr sparsam
versucht hatten zwar leute erst mal eine
sehr straße baute das heißt es gibt ein
zweites mädchen vom entität es gibt
substanzen konkrete substanzen auf der
einen seite also will marco hausmänner
und ich auch und auf der anderen seite
und wie werden die dinge etwas aussagen
mensch person persönlich seine person
sein wissen dinge von andys aussagen es
sind so allgemeinen eigenschaften größer
als einen meter seien usw sofort also
das sind die einzigen zwei entitäten die
es gibt und was man sagt in diesem in
diesem haus setzen das sind auch alles
an dem neuen auftritt so ereignisse oder
zustände
die gibt es doch gar nicht weder
universale eigenschaften sondern und die
sind auch keine substanzen sondern wenn
überhaupt dann sind es konkret
beschaffen ist sowieso versteht man
normalerweise angst so die interessante
frage ist jetzt also das heißt vermögen
als ebenso eine art der art von ntt
möseneder substanzen noch ungesund
eigenschaften die akzeptiert
es gibt handlung normalerweise und
seinen handlungen in der einzel- und
werde er seine ganz eindeutig der armen
es ist die frage gibt es in st
also wissen so diese metaphysische gehen
können doch mangels schauen auch zu
wissen seien darauf setzen dass er
trotzdem und handlungen
wir müssen wir einfach mal wirklich ein
bisschen und zb mich interessiert die
frage einfach wie auch person und
freiheit zusammen hängen weil wer ist
denn frei also das objekt der freiheit
er spricht immer so als gäbe es die
freiheit gut vielleicht aus dem
logischen metaphysischen hintergrund
aber es ist ja immer nur die freiheit
ist ja nicht eine substanz sondern weit
ist eine qualifikation eines objekts was
frei ist im handeln und das würde mich
auch mal interessieren wer ist
eigentlich dass objekte freiheiten ich
versuche städtischen überlegungen würde
in opposition zu stimmen also würde dann
nur sagen wenn ich so was sagen die
versorgung es ist nicht möglich ist
nämlich streng mit der physisch form
gibt wenn ich dann von der freiheit
sprechen von vermögen oder von
handlungen
ich denke ja durchaus sagen letztlich
sind es personen die preise in ganz ganz
in seinem sinne vielleicht nicht ganz so
bremsen er würde jetzt sagen personen
also müssen wir also ersten animalis an
ihm all ist also animalis muss bedeutet
wir als personen sind eigentlich nur
besonders intelligente tiere also wir
sind wesentlich unsere identität ist
identität unseres beliebten organismus
und nicht irgendwie so eine seele die
dann noch existiert auch nicht so eine
subjektivität oder so was wir sind
einfach sehr intelligente tiere
bailey das ist ein jüngerer der bei der
die ganzen aufsätze auf seiner homepage
hat der das auch so ein animalis gibt es
noch den recall sondern unsere riesen
debatte dass wir eigentlich sind es
interessiert mich persönlich vor allem
ob wir eben als personen nur tiere sind
oder nicht nur ein bisschen mehr ohne
dann ins und tourismus zu kommen wie bei
descartes dass man sagt es gibt eine
denkende substanz und der ausgedehnte
substanz riesen debatten lage habe ich
finde wir sollten die am rande auch
etwas berühren jeden fans indem wir den
freiheitsbegriff darauf zurück
zurückführen oder zurück beziehen
er ist ein bisschen trocken das müssen
wir schon mal sagen also man darf
durchaus auch mal ein bisschen
provozieren weil er von sich aus erstmal
nicht so viel sagt so meine meine
erfahrung gewesen aber hast du ein
bisschen mehr erfahrung noch gemacht
also ein bisschen erst mal so ein
bisschen ruhiger typ aber ich denke wir
müssen jetzt ein bisschen aus der
reserve er hat ja sehr viele sehr für
uns also nicht zimperlich sein mit ihren
fragen trauen sie sich ja
im überblick
war auch nicht werden
hier finde ich finde ich ein guter punkt
den man auch noch am rande betreffen
könnte gibt es unabhängig von der
unterscheidung von negativer fallen und
metaphysischer freiheit gibt es in
diesem konzept der metaphysischen
freiheit noch verschiedene unterhalten
sowie ästhetische freiheit
das meint sie offensichtlich
ja kann man noch erbringen
das risiko dass wir natürlich haben wir
neben fragen zum begriff der freiheit
denis dass er einfach darauf antwortet
er möchte es ist eine unterart oder das
ist eine ausprägung der metaphysischen
fall könnte man doch auch sagen das sind
alles fälle dieser art von freiheit oder
die kreative freiheit ist ja auch nicht
nur sowas inneres rauszulassen sozusagen
sondern seine handlungsfreiheit sondern
es sagt ja auch keiner also mit der
reflektierten reflektierenden
urteilskraft das hat was mit intelligenz
zu tun mit die frage ist inwiefern eine
willensbildung mit dem spiel ist weil
bei kant ja das ästhetische vom
moralischen recht verschieden ist nur
anna logisch zu verstehen ist aber ich
denke es wäre zu eng gefasst ästhetische
freiheit nur als form von
handlungsfreiheit aufzufassen ich glaube
da muss mehr mit dem spiel sein
und dann kann man durchaus denke ich
diese frage stellen darf so was wie
ästhetische freiheit wie sich zum zum
metaphysischen freien feld ja genau
jetzt sagt er hier nach unten eben
also es gibt ebenso einige leute wie der
regierung john stuart mill und haupt und
so und die waren eben groß vertreter
dieser auffassung dass es nur eben diese
freiheit hier das nur die thematisch
werden solle
also dass nur in meinen worten jetzt
handlungsfreiheit thematisch ist wie zum
beispiel john locke sagt der ist jetzt
nicht drin also lok und auch um die
sagen der gibt also john rock sagt der
gedanke von willensfreiheit sein wurden
bestimmen zu wollen
der ist sinnlos das ist ein völliger ist
eine illusion ist dass diese fragen zum
schein problem willens freien sagen
viele im puristischen denke dass also
diese im posten sind deshalb will das
sind diese tradition sie sagen also
metaphysische freiheit brauchen wir
nicht ist sinnlos ist wir brauchen wir
diese freiheit zu letztendlich eher
freiheit von um handlungsfähig zu sein
könnten
ja ok und jetzt kommt hier so eine
analogie mit diesen göttlichen wissen
vorher wissen und da sieht man natürlich
wenn solche begriffe wie gott ins spiel
kommen dann haben wir gleich hier
metaphysik mit ihm damals gleich mit
meter für sich zu tun und hier unten
führt er jetzt diesen begriff können sie
vielleicht noch mal sagen was jetzt
genau metaphysische freiheit ist wir
haben jetzt hier negative freiheit die
betrifft solche freiheiten von solchen
kontexten wie politik wirtschaft
psychologie
was ist jetzt dagegen metaphysische
freiheit haben sie eine idee
neuhaus nächste noch dazulernen wie
jetzt sagt er hier eine simple world
express is the concept of metaphysiker
für den englisch ist kann also hier
kommt jetzt der zentrale begriff und was
hat es jetzt mit dem können auf sich
warum ist können ein metaphysischer
begriff wir würden doch normalerweise
sagen können ist doch irgendwie sowas
was im alltag immer so auch auf
handlungsebene rolle spielt ich kann das
tun
ich bin handlungsfähig kann das tun
also warum ist jetzt hier können jetzt
ihr das entscheiden
da können nochmals nächste zitat
vielleicht dazu da unterscheidet jetzt
hier nochmal gesagt es gibt neben jetzt
vieldeutigkeit von können da bringt er
dann das beispiel seiner mutter seines
verwandten eine kranke verwandte ältere
verwandte und dann will jetzt jemand
diesen kranken verwandten mit dem er
verwandt ist nicht bei sich aufnehmen
dann sagt man zu dieser person das
kannst du doch nicht tun
ja natürlich kann kann man das tun
man ist frei dazu aber das ist dann so
ein moralischer sind das kannst du doch
nicht wollen so eine rede davon also
jedenfalls kann man hierbei
metaphysischer freiheit mal schon mal
drunter schreiben können also das ist
jedes zentrale begriff was hat es mit
diesem können noch auf sich da ist
natürlich die led wieder mit also können
im sinne des vermögens natürlich auch
ihr vermögen schreibt jetzt mal klein
vermögen etwas zu tun
was haben sie noch andere assoziationen
mit dem können und warum es metaphysisch
genannt werden soll
manchmal sagen wenn ich nur so was wie
ich meine natürlich kann man bei einem
meeting natürlich wieder sprechen und
sagen ob ich bin frei gestellt an
öffentlichen meetings widersprechen also
können und frei sein benutzen wir
manchmal auszusparen gebracht und da es
ist ein interessanter weise immer so
dass sie sagen wir wöchentlich kann will
ich bin frei sowie das vielleicht so
vorstellen man sagen zum gesagt ich kann
ich bin frei dass das wollte jetzt auch
gerade sagen das immer so etwas
positives drin ich bin in der lage auch
so bin ich bin der position kann es also
ich kann es wirklich oder da ist schon
so soll dieses dieses auch
selbstbewusstsein mit enthalten etwas
wirklich realisieren zu können
natürlich stellt sich dann wieder hier
die frage wie das mit der negativen
freiheit das am hang ich kann es ja auch
nur weil ich nicht unfrei darin bin oder
nicht darin gebunden
ja also
das sagt auch an einer stelle aufgegeben
dass er sagt also man könnte meinen also
abwesenheit von hindernissen ist
notwendig damit der physischen oder sein
kanal selbst weil ich mit hindernissen
überwinden kann also nur weil es ein
hindernis gibt es auch nicht dass ich
ein hindernis gibt mein geschäft auf und
ins gesicht zu widersprechen heißt das
noch nicht dass ich mich jetzt wieder
das gesicht widersprechen kann oder dass
die geburten aber das hindernis könnte
eben in mir selbst liegen also in mir
selbst in einem film gemäß gibt um
überwinden dann also in einem gewissen
sinn von negative freiheit also einem
gewissen sinn also sagen einem starken
sind ist negative freiheit schon
notwendig damit der physischen das
könnte man vielleicht sagen also im
starken sind wenn man meint
unüberwindlich hin wenn also die
abwesenheit unüberwindlich erinnert dass
die muss natürlich gegeben sein damit
ich bestimmte dinge zum kaffee aber dass
er dann sagt die post ist was sind wir
eigentlich unüberwindliche
dann kommt das und dann kann ich nicht
dann habe ich eben dieses genau alle
sind praktisch nicht frei sein zu tun
etwas etwas zu tun können und da kommt
das können dann eben wieder rein
[Musik]
da war noch eine bildung er ist ganz
hinten und dann hier
physisch alles in der welt zu schaffen
ist
verschiedene alternativen auf dem stehen
und jemand der mich kennt macht das wie
alternativen zu nehmen ich denke schon
also bestimmte aufsätze beim in der
natur ist also eher sagt der sprecher
hob in futures sagt also wenn
metaphysische gegeben ist dann gibt es
mehr als eine zukunft ins offene während
wenn keine bitte physische zeit haben
[Musik]
diese benutzte auf
genau
ja möglichkeit ihren sinnen erlebt haben
und da wahrscheinlich ja also dann würde
das von innen tagen wahrscheinlich sagen
dass die gelegenheit haben dass sich
einige die möglichkeit bietet ist mit
hochwertigen dafür dass man mit der
schütze in diesen habe es auf das
reichen also ich kann zum beispiel die
gelegenheit haben
also ich vielleicht wenig auf 500 meter
entfernung von sommer in hamburg hat ein
gewehr in der hand und hätten sie die
mehrheiten zu schießen aber verdächtig
animation von millimetern kann
interessierten ihn erschießen das heißt
dann endlich die gelegenheit werden aber
trotzdem nicht freuen uns immer so
bisher keine rechte
da müsse man mehr sagen zusammen also
gute gelegenheit die fähigkeit
vielleicht auch soll also die man muss
in der richtigen inneren psychischen und
physischen verfassung
ja also das ist es gebe ich ihnen recht
man könnte dazwischen schwächeren und
stärkeren scheiben naturaplan sind nicht
die guten punkt also die die schwächen
wird
ich habe etwas tun
das waren einfach schön richtig
schließen dass wegen schwarzarbeit um
stärker sind
ich kann etwas tun was er tun würde das
sicher dazu fünf wir dass er stirbt weil
somit würde die schlafen werde ich dann
für einige staaten nicht wert ist du
etwa dann war erstmal sprachlos problem
sein sagte huber
zusagen muss ich bin so frei und keine
konsequenzen bedeuten dass dieser ihn an
ich kann jetzt schon sagen möglich dann
werde ich weiterhin fragen linken spalte
konsequenzen ziehen
das hat ihr können ich denke schon also
die es kommt doch an diesen satz haben
wir nochmal so also normalfall das ist
ja so ich bin deswegen nicht frei zu
sagen oder ich kann es ihnen nicht sagen
in diesem sinn weil es bestimmte
konsequenzen hätte
im job familie und so weiter und ich bin
nicht bereit diese konsequenzen tragen
und wenn ich dann sage ich bin trotzdem
frei heißt es irgendwie okay ich hab die
ich habe ihr klar gemacht dass das für
konsequenzen hätte und im bereich diese
konsequenzen auf mich zu nehmen
mein vater hat mir dann geht es geht
also ja also ich heute einen doch
aufmerksam machen dass ihr sprachliches
oft austauschen
ich will nicht sagen dass wenn ich dann
so etwas sage das ist dann immer wir
können mit den metaphysischen sein muss
es gibt sicher fälle in denen in dem das
recht haben wo man sowas vielleicht sagt
ich bin nicht drei uns ein trotzdem kann
man es nicht bereit die konsequenzen zu
tragen
das entsprechende weiter
[Musik]
wir haben und wir haben wirklich dieses
erde und die mir
im winter mehr gefahren und auf viel
mehr als das
möglichkeit als dieses foto jacobi
wir wissen
heute war
oder vertikalen
[Musik]
das ist hübsch anzusehen zu den fragen
wie es kommen also wenn es so wäre wie
sie sagen
und wenn wir jetzt mal die 6000 könnte
wenn wir die deterministisch verstehen
das gibt es eben zur frage sind
determinismus metaphysisches waldverein
also können wir wohl vergangenheit
naturgesetze uns festlegen
die haben über
also
also meint sie so was wie spontanität ja
das ist das natürlich auch begriffe die
man mit dem können in verbindung setzen
müssen also und und da
[Musik]
das ist dann wieder die frage nach den
alternativen möglichkeiten und frankfurt
mit dem ich auch von ihm wegen
konfrontieren würde wie er sich zu
diesem zu dieser frage verhält bei harry
frankfurt wie es mit alternativen
möglichkeiten und können also wie es
wieder sich dazu verhält aber da kommen
wir jetzt gleich noch drauf wenn es
jetzt ich mache mir noch versus können
[Musik]
dass eben die frage wie sich jetzt
metaphysische freiheit können vermögen
zu alternativen möglichkeiten verhält
wie er dieses verhältnis jetzt darstellt
das ist jetzt die spannende genau dann
würde ich sagen machen wir weiter
jetzt gibt es diese konfessionen die
schon erklärt hat mit dieser die kamera
springt das jetzt das hier da sagt du
kannst doch nicht deine mutter nicht zu
dir nehmen
you have used to take your mother
interview haus das kannst du doch nicht
machen kann man kommt für natürlichkeit
das machen aber ich mache es nicht weil
ich eben anständiger mensch bin und ein
guter sohn oder eine gute tochter da was
auch immer also ich könnte natürlich als
hier ist eben die metaphysische freiheit
jetzt nicht gemacht damit er es
eigentlich gesagt du sollst das tun ist
damit ein ich gesagt du sollst das tun
sollen impliziert können aber sollen
impliziert eben auch nicht nicht also
das nichts zu tun
ja also wer soll wer etwas tun soll
der muss es auch können aber er kann es
natürlich auch nicht wollen
ich sag jetzt mal man hat die freiheit
auch gegen das sollen zu zuwider zu
handeln das ist ein ganz spannendes
lache das ist ja auch immer man sieht
das ja immer nur in einer hinsicht wer
soll wer etwas soll der
kann es tun muss es aber nicht das ist
eben auch eine wichtige unterscheidung
weil häufig denkt man dann ja wer ist
soll der muss es tun
auch wer es muss im moralischen sinne
jetzt bei dem sollen der wäre es
eigentlich sollte wäre es muss der kann
natürlich auch dagegen handeln aber er
weiß natürlich ich tue es jetzt bewusst
entgegen den forderungen
hier stellt sich dann wieder die frage
nach der quelle des sollens also ist
sollen ist sollen jetzt hier moralisch
zu verstehen normativ sicherlich das
scheint mir normativer begriff zu sein
sollen ist es metaphysisch fragezeichen
das ist es dpa oder was ist vom
lateinischen die beere ist müssen sollen
ja richtig all das ist so ein sonderfall
dass jetzt eine ambiguität im wort
können
das kann man jetzt mal so ein bisschen
überspringen und jetzt haben wir hier
jetzt diese verwendung von können wie
sie im metaphysischen sinne wichtig ist
jetzt bringt er hier drei sätze
also er wird in der lage sein hier tätig
zu sein wird das treffen
so darf sie nicht beschuldigen dass sie
das treffen verpasst hat sie konnte sie
hatte keine wahl
in dieser hinsicht es lag nicht in
meiner gewalt dieses treffen
das vermögen das mobility ist ja hier
wieder bildeten vermögen und die eine
wahl haben war also war das sollte
vielleicht den begriff sollten wir auch
noch die hand schreiben zu mögen wahl
haben die wahl haben die wahrheit haben
etwas zu tun oder zu wollen
also man kann herr und lebensfreude
denke ich bei jedem begriff nochmal
eigenes unterscheiden das ist das
interessiert mich sehr dieses verhältnis
von negativer freiheit und metaphysische
freiheit zu auch noch positiver freiheit
und dann noch willens folgen
handlungsfeld ja ich bin auch der
meinung dass man nicht sagen kann sollte
negative freie gleich handlungsfreiheit
aber ich glaube es ist sehr nahe damit
verbunden und die frage ist es nur
aspekte das aber das ist eine frage die
mir auf den nägeln brennt die ich ihn
unbedingt stellen möchte
und die sind jetzt illustrationen dieses
mit den metaphysischen gehalt von können
weiter zu reformieren
auch noch gewalt haben power gemacht
haben
die macht die wahl die die macht haben
gewalt
kann man für oder haben sie dazu noch
ein foto das uns normal weitergehen
sonst das ist leuchtet ja eigentlich
recht ein okay und jetzt kannst du was
zu diesem herrn sagen die jetzt hier
genannten
ist zusammen mit diesem bereich eine
mögliche konsequenz aus den sechziger
jahren neu formuliert hat strenger
formuliert schon bekannt ich schreibe es
mir hier hin
oder soll ich es irgendwo hier
unternehmen eigentlich nicht das ist ja
das hängt mit der metaphysischen
freiheit zusammen aber es ist zeit
demonstriert er nicht die metaphysische
freiheit schreibt mir hinter konsequenz
also dass konsequenz argument versucht
eben zu zeigen dass keine handlung
metaphysisch kaiser und was sie bekommen
ist eine sehr intuitive und ihre umwelt
und wenn ich bis dahin akzeptiert als er
gerade teile schon mal inkompatibel ist
dass wir glauben dass determinismus und
metaphysische freiheit unfall und das
ist das argument für den inkompatibel
ist muss und später wird schon in waren
dann so ein paar bedingungen machen was
man daraus konsequenzen ziehen muss wenn
man das einzige tier soll es aber
vorerst kalt er sieht auch winfried
hassemer station ist vom rand aus
salzburg sind recht gut schuljahr
komplett in santos action also alles was
wir tun können
das einzige was wir tun können ist der
vergangenheit etwas hinzuzufügen
wir können an der vergangenheit selber
können
das ist die frage natürlich ob es nicht
so etwas gibt wie zeitreisen und so dass
es ein riesen debatte aber so auch
unsere intuition wir haben eine starke
intuition dass wir das nicht können
ich werde in meinem vortrag auf der
tagung werde ich da ein paar
fragezeichen
aber okay ist eine intuition ist wir
können vor der letzten der vier blöcke
des tschechischen pass von forster
also ich gehe auf rache aus essen
ein heiliges serien welche wunder wirken
kann und deswegen können sie auch nur
dass der vergangenheit also etwas der
vergangenheit hinzufügen was im
einzelnen die natur mittel ist so sie
können weder an der vergangenheit etwas
ändern noch können sie an die
naturgesetze
alles was sie tun können muss im
einklang sein mit der vergangenheit und
dem naturgesetz
politisch ist der pass wird konnte die
journalistik seiner großartigen menschen
wird der schönste moment of merkur
märkte für dieses investment beide
turner switches betriebes das erwartet
major astrid können die mitgliedschaft
wenn er den feminismus war es dann ist
alles was wir dann sind die einzigen
verfügungen wir machen fortsetzungen des
gesetzes
und wir können eigentlich gar nichts
richtig hin können in dem sinne hin zu
setzen weil es wir werden hinzugesetzt
oder so eine dieses hinzusetzen würde ja
immer so auch implizieren sollen können
das sind zu setzen oder das hin zu
setzen im sinne der handlungsfreiheit
mit sie denn mit der physischen freiheit
also wenn ich also stellen wir uns vor
ich gehe ich gehen
zum verrückt machen der sagt weiß der
geschmack oder weiß durchgeschnitten es
liegt dann sie haben die wahl
wenn er determinismus war als dann kann
ich nur das tun was sie tatsächlich zu
also wenn ich weiß nicht warum
dann ist es das einzige was ich tun kann
brauchen wir mal ich könnte auch
weißbier
obwohl ich weiß wie gar nicht genommen
habe naja wenn er den termin ist es wahr
ist dann würde ihm ein beispiel nehmen
endlich mit den gesetzen widersprechen
oder der vergangenheit ich kann aber
weder etwas den naturgesetzen
widerspricht also machen wir doch mal
her grafik also das ist jetzt die
gegenwart hier diese grenze und das ist
die vergangenheit die schraffierte ich
jetzt mal hier so ein stückchen es ist
ja auch so räumliche vorstellung ich
finde das ist die vergangenheit die
sonnenstrom der ist erstarrt wie so ein
lavastrom oder sohn der ruht jetzt bin
ich hier und jetzt ist die frage was
setzt sich jetzt daran genau die die
frage ist das ist so wie es tatsächlich
ausgehen will
einmal das und hier wäre vielleicht eine
alternative den stift sind jetzt besser
wenn wir das in zwei alternativen ich
hab die frist ist eine echte alternative
für mich diese alternative obwohl ich
mich tatsächlich also ich nehme das habe
ich gesagt sich nicht mehr weiß wohl
stehen geschmack beim verrückt manchmal
habe ich nehme nicht weiß wie lieberman
ich würde wahrnehmen wenn er
determinismus weise würden implizieren
dass entweder die naturgesetze anders
sind wurde die vergangenen tagen aber
ich kenne die gesetze ändern noch die
vergangenheit also ist es die einzige
das einzige was ich tun kann ist die
kultur ist das display selbst
der termin ist wissen wir also diese
wahl haben war ist da nicht drin und
deswegen ist habe ich so ein bisschen
das problem ich habe es nicht vergessen
mit dem können also natürlich wir müssen
an die sagen wir müssen das tun wir
müssen das tun und ist die frage können
wir das tun wir müssen das war mein
problem
wir müssen es tun die rede von können
hier was wir hin zu setzen können was
wären zu setzen müssen oder die frage ob
wir überhaupt als personalpronomen da
noch eine rolle spielen was sich durch
uns durchsetzt also die gesetze treiben
durch uns hindurch und bewegen uns
dorthin also wir sind letztendlich
gewisse instrumente oder durchlauf
stationen von gesetzen und von potenzen
die sich hinter uns in der vergangenheit
schon angebaute aufgestaut haben
ja also genau also eine also zieht
daraus eine konfuse und wir können nicht
anders handeln tatsächlich haben wir
könnten unseren anderen kitas erklären
er seitdem gehört natürlich zu recht
aber es wird nicht so dass wenn wir
können das es impliziert dass johansson
können und es gibt viele neben zustimmen
würde
und wenn das so ist dann können wir
daraus liegen folgern dass wenig anders
halb werden sondern können wir das
überhaupt nicht es kann nicht sein dass
der hand ich würde sagen kann im prinzip
lässt jetzt nicht mehr raus sagt alles
erfolglos dass wir wenn überhaupt etwas
tun können dann nur das was wir tastet
das heißt wir können niemals anders ja
keine alternative
wir müssen erkennen und dann kann man
natürlich noch weitere spannende frage
da war noch eine meldung dazu bitte also
ob man da einfach noch von können
sprechen kann dieser hinsicht oder ob
man nicht eher von müssen sprechen
sollte
[Musik]
eines seiner argumente mit sein
kommendes breite und tiefe unserer
kritik akzeptiert dies sehr hoch
komplizierte ökonomische theorie ist
argument der sagt frey dpa - im
mittleren vater ich bin irgendwie kommen
immer wieder auch die welt müsse der
positionen und esel zurückkehren also
inkompatibel ist gut dann macht man die
doch wir haben noch zeit wenn sie nicht
noch dazu ohne frage haben dann können
wir eigentlich weitermachen
ok und jetzt sagt er hier also fd
argument ist korrekt sfz reviews die
adia wird mir der physiker vor mir
liegen negativ konnte wenn dieses
argument richtig ist dann widerlegt ist
die idee das metaphysische freiheit ein
floß negatives konzept ist also hier
kommt jetzt negativ und positive
schwingt so ein bisschen mit seiner idee
ist bei den determinismus impliziert
nicht dass etwas ständig unsere daran
hindert sich zu enthalten
und deswegen wäre negative freiheit gibt
es negative freitauchen sich
der müsste einfach wir haben es hier
über ein argument ist zeigt dass
freiheit oder mit der physische freien
journalismus und veranstalter können
dasselbe sein
ich habe jetzt hier noch mit
fragezeichen handlungsfreiheit
hingeschrieben mit fragezeichen weil
wenn ich jetzt nur handlungs frei wäre
dann wäre auch das wie gesagt diese
fortsetzung dieses weißwurstessen hand
form von handlungsfreiheit also
handlungsfreiheit ist mit dem konsequenz
argument völlig kompatibel oder völlig
unproblematisch oder in diesem sinne
also kommt darauf an also tun können
wenn wir jetzt tun
genau bei können halt in diesem sinne
der metaphysischen freiheit wie eben
fand in wildes unterschied
ja das ist die frage die frage ist halt
er bringt können nur hier ins spiel und
nicht im sinne der negativen freiheit da
spielt macht er das können so stark im
metaphysischen zimmer
das ist meine gedacht also zumindest
sind also negativ weil da kommt das wort
können dann vermag auch ein bisschen
beantworten und ich hatte gedacht dass
ich lieben sind gemeint
wenn wir das beim namen kam dann könnte
man auch nicht verhandlungsfähig
könnte man nicht ist aber spannende
frage das ist die wirkliche frage können
wir dann noch können wir mit verträgt
sich handlungsfreiheit mit dem
konsequenz argumente willensfreiheit
nicht deswegen müsste realismus wie
sieht's mit handlungsfreiheit aus und
wie sieht es mit dem können aus auch
bezogen auf handlungsfreiheit die er
hier nicht ins spiel bringen also ich
arbeite versuche zu zeigen das ist
konsequenz argument letztlich nicht nur
zeigen also alle sind sich einig dass
konsequenzen und sagt wir können nicht
anders
tatsächlich aber ich versuche zeigen
dass wir überhaupt gar nichts tun können
wenn es konsequenz also mensch stimmt
ich glaube das sagt anerkennend fehler
aber wenn das stimmt dann können wir
können wir überhaupt nächsten und genau
jetzt denken meine meinung ist die
konsequenz argument dass jemand der das
vertritt vielleicht einfach ein paar
namen zu geben ist alles drin
hätten wir dieses professorin und viel
verrät eine position die er als agent im
habe man muss natürlich jetzt noch die
ästhetische dimension auch noch mit
reinem also die frage nach dem
selbstverständnis könnte nicht einfach
diese dieses konsequenz argument wenn es
jetzt uns einschränkt alternative
handlungsoptionen zu wählen
dennoch dazu führen dass wir wenn wir
jetzt den naturgesetzen einfach folgen
das aber bewusst tun dass wir das im
sinne der handlungsfreiheit einfach
interpretieren dass also
handlungsfreiheit immer auch so eine art
von selbstverständnis ist wie man den
naturgesetzen unterliegt also das ist
einfach nur im modus der selbstreflexion
dieses determinismus ist ja dann wäre es
dann wäre es kompatibel damit dann wäre
es eben eine epidemische lesart von oder
eine phänomenologische ließ
[Musik]
wendigkeit natürlich kann jemand an als
er tatsächlich und trotzdem genau das
ist diese app historische dimension an
da ist pino sein guter stichwortgeber
gibt es beispiel dass ein stein der
durch die luft geworfen wird da ist der
sich auch frei fühlen würde darin wir in
der luft fliegt weil es einfach seine
natur ist genauso könnte man auch sagen
unsere natur ist einfach den
naturgesetzen zu unterliegen und dem wir
immerhin das vermögen haben darauf zu
reflektieren ist das handlungsfreiheit
einstein jetzt oder ein bloßer
gegenstand und ein baum der eben auch so
wie wir den naturgesetzen unterliegt
aber eben keinen keine quali arg eine
phänomenale bewusstheit davon hat der
wäre eben dann nicht handlungsfähig
das heißt also man könnte es
handlungsfreiheit auch so und so
bestimmt das gesagt ist dazu noch ist
dazu bald dabei noch phänomenales
bewusstsein vorhanden
wenn ja dann wird es als können in
diesem schwachen es in den bergen um
ebendiese bewusstheit des vollzugs
unabhängig davon ob ich auch anders
hätte haben können wenn nicht dann ist
es eben so was wie diese schlechte
notwendigkeit also die eben nichts mit
handlungsfreiheit zu dunkel
wir sind jetzt schon dabei die sagen so
nebenmann wir akzeptieren zwar haben wir
dann auch funktionen eine option
das ist eine sehr drastische
die pferde eigentlich anlass dieses
jubiläums wenn der preis war zweitweise
weiß leuchten und ich glaube ich die
beste situation
das wäre aber wir können einen anderen
sind wir trotzdem und so verstehen wenn
wir sagen besteht eben in dem
bewusstsein genauen spinosa wer also
eine sehr radikale möglichkeit auf
dieses argument aber es ist möglich
wir werden jetzt von dem wagen wird
jetzt verschiedene möglichkeiten auch
durch soll man das vielleicht noch
machen wir das noch genau machst du mal
das ganze also im sinne von michael
fischer frei dann ziemlich frei weil es
muss ein bisschen humor als reaktion auf
seine kosten
fünf fraktionen der erste wäre zu sagen
also wendel determinismus weise bin ich
frei für den es wahlweise mit frei das
ist der genannten gegen eine harte den
termin ist mit dem wissen glaubt dass
von dem terminus in grove versteht sich
und dass er mit uns war es dauert also
da investiert also dabei die moderne
physik da ein bisschen vorsichtiger ist
so es gibt viel was sollte sprich dass
sie nicht in eine dicke minister gewesen
sind aber so genau wissen das natürlich
ist auch der wissenschaften lager so
könnte man auch sagen und wir wissen
sicher präsidenten sind das kann sein
kann aber natürlich sein
wir wissen aber wenn er war ist ganz
befreit also wissen wir nicht aufhalten
kann sein kann aber nicht das wäre in so
genannte klassizistische position
exorzismus
das ist in zeiten zu antworten weil es
natürlich unbefriedigend und die
epidemische lesart scheint mir sehr
unbefriedigend zu sein
was bringt mir das also sie sehen es
geht hier um unter logische frage
stellen wie ist es und nicht nur wie es
nicht aber das theologische dimension
wird natürlich dann besonders
interessant wenn es um dieses biosa
beispiel geht da zeigt sich eben die
ganze relevant ist okay jetzt machen wir
das nächste noch mal
thilo sarrazin ist eine höhere führung
manuela mölgg it s
bevor wir den computerbildschirm
determinismus zufrieden
dies fiel aus da vorher passiert ist die
kommunisten auf die nahen osten meldeten
passt und erwirtschaften dass jetzt die
so genannte position indifferent ismus
und ja also das wetter lässt uns warum
weil sie planen wir sind frei wir wissen
dass wir bereit sind
wir wissen aber auch dass welt
determinismus war es das dann nicht frei
sind also wissen beziehen
genau damit geht noch nicht einher dass
es in deterministisch sein muss so nur
oder folgt daraus dass wenn der
terrorismus falsch ist dass der in der
termin ist muss wahr ist ich bin mir
auch nicht sicher ob daraus folgt ob das
kann sich auch mal überlegen ob
determinismus und in determinismus ob
das begriffliche schon ist es natürlich
die negation dessen also nicht
determiniert
aber ganz schlüssig scheint wie das auch
nicht die negation ist
aber wenn der index folgt daraus nicht
dass irgendeine menschliche handlung im
detail
das ist das problem es kann sein dass
von allen menschlichen hand oder mit
terminiert sind obwohl er in den termin
ist und zwar deswegen hast du schon
recht als wirklich ein problem
und wie gesagt professor hochrhein wird
hat immer oder auch musste woche auf
diesen touren
spannend naja ok also hier geht es jetzt
um lieber tourismus den schreiben auch
noch mal hin lieber trabis muss da
werden wir ja den haben wir aber die
position haben wir auch auf diesem
zettel den sie alle in der ersten
sitzung bekommen haben und den sie aber
auch auf die lowcost finden mit den
verschiedenen positionen lieber
tourismus heißt wir sind frei und
deswegen ist der determinismus falsch
und dann ist halt die frage was folgt
daraus folgt daraus dass ein liberta
riss in der termin ismus annehmen muss
das ist schalten auch nicht klar zu sein
dass er das deswegen annehmen muss kann
er nicht sich dagegen in different
verhalten oder kann dann vielleicht noch
mal schrittes annehmen das sollte man
auch noch offen lassen ist jetzt erstmal
nicht so zentral natürlich auch wichtig
weil die tat
hilmar thate aber erst im sommer naht
und er sagt als ich schreib doch mal hin
robert kahn das ist der der bekannteste
liberta robert den behandeln wir
natürlich auch noch aber erst nachdem
wir das wäre das hier setzt ja schon
voraus ist es eine das militär meniskus
erläutert dass die daten mit und so wie
er definiert ist es den ist es sicher
die fahrt aber es gibt trotzdem probleme
aber das mussten uns nicht attraktiv
mein arzt oder in der ersten reihe des
postens das ist ein wichtiger punkt weil
natürlich wir sagen dass die
wissenschaftliche fragen bist du dir
sicher
können einfach aus unserem gefühle
freiheit
also sagen wir sollten es geschafft aber
den bewegungen der grand design und
bereitstellung der grund nach komplett
ins internet und unfallstatistik muss
man fragen sind das vielleicht
installation aus und manager im
internistischen vermeiden einen
harmlosen im alten filme zu prüfen
also ist es besser wenn wir gebeten sich
aber nicht so schlimm an komfort
mitgelaufen deterministisch bet award
the bobs in linz ist bewusst dann wäre
schon besser
was haben keine ohren haft
eingeschleuster v twins of the futures
bekam sektor also gut gehabt da gibt es
eben mehrere mögliche zukunft
künftig kann man dann wird jetzt auch
interesse
brauch find ich schon die lösung zur
zukunft der märkte nützen könnte
wie kann jemand wie kann es mir irgend
welche dieser möglichen zukunft
[Musik]
wissenschaftsrat ist wünschst du kannst
dann wüsste nicht an einen zufall dass
diese zugriffe zukunft intelligente
konstant halten
und wenn die leute bevorzugen wenn es
mal gelebt hatte gesagt
so wurden die termin ist wissen wie das
wetter auf den speed herren gewonnen
stellen uns vor dass so ein bisschen
gedankenexperiment anstrengung
scoreboard würde auch die einsätze dort
und würde die das ganze universum noch
mal vielleicht fünf minuten zurückspulen
und wenn das universum in die technisch
ist dann ist es nicht gesagt dass das
universum wieder genauso ablaufen wie es
tatsächlich abgelaufen ist sondern es
könnte auch anders
und diese tatsache sagte man könne sich
vorstellen dass er das 10.000 mal macht
und das ist vielleicht um 57 prozent der
fälle so ausfällt und in 42 prozent der
fälle so ausfällt und wenn wir das so
machen würde würde ich sagen irgendwie
macht es keinen unterschied
es ist irgendwie eine reine zufall sache
ob das im universum sohn ausfällt oder
so aus und wenn der eine zug fast also
wenn sich abhängig von unseren
überlegungen entscheidung ist dann
scheint die adler weiter wüsten werden
verläuft also auch die handel mit aktien
standen gesetzlich nur ein produkt des
zufalls zu sagen also wir scheinen
trotzdem keine kontrolle unserer
handlung zu haben und plötzlich machen
zufalls geschichte ist auch jetzt bei
uns heute abend
mein professor anhöhe inwieweit wenn es
der reine zufall sache ist dann habe ich
keine kontrolle scheint irgendwie da für
mich verantwortlich sein
das ist auch nicht ganz stark intuition
hinten gesehen also in diesem werk im
unterschied zum frequency argument dass
es gibt noch detaillierter beschreibung
auf der bank einen formal präzises
argument insofern bin ich da auch ein
bisschen skeptisch weil weil sie gesagt
man an die tür intuition abonniert und
er sagte auch er glaubt dass hier wohl
fehler ist aber eher seien weder jemand
anderes hat die leitung ist der arm
wurde und deswegen bis bald ein
geheimnis das ist glaube ich ziemlich
klar an oder haben sie dazu noch fragen
zu diesem termin ist muss problem zu
fall natürlich kann man wieder fragen
was ist genau dies zufall
da kann man sich weiter fragen wie
verhältst mit der quantenphysik so in
der termin ist ische zustände wie
spielen die dann rein in unsere
entscheidungen und zu oder spontanität
brauchte nicht so ein moment des in
determinierten die spontanität
[Musik]
ist es wirklich und vor allem ohne
freiheit aber es kann natürlich in die
termine sind dass sich diese handlung
vollziehen trotzdem kann die gründe und
die partie das hat mir noch zwei meldung
erst hier und dann hier ja
aber es besteht nicht
widersprochen
warum
beide programme sind schön
der gast
das ist bei dem
durch
also den längen letzte den widerspruch
darin das hatte etwas was ihnen zugefügt
habe was einige wichtigste werk das an
anderer stelle
es gibt noch ein zitat werden wir mit
den zeitungen zu lesen also wenn es
wirklich eine frage ist ob ich mich so
umschaue dann scheint auch nicht mehr
die aus natürlich nicht ausreichend
kontrolle zwar etwas liegt letztlich
dann nicht mehr an mir die entscheidung
so hoch ist und west einen unfall hat
sich die frage ist wie schaffen sie es
finde schlecht ist ist auf ihren blick
ist es wirklich so dass meine eltern uns
war es dass wir dann schon zufall zu
verdanken
das wird auch ein grund sein professor
buchhalterin werden auf der tagung der
ansprechen wird und der vips also und
lässt damit auch hin wenn das handy cam
indes muss bald ist es
andere das ist dass damit nur noch weit
ist dass trotzdem alles eingeräumt
bestimmt ist in dem sinne dass wir dort
auf die wiese passen würde das ist jedes
mal wieder in die andere richtung und
schlanke und große gießen ist kompatibel
mit der minister die verstehen
wir nehmen die ganzen vorträge auf und
stellen sie dann auf filou cast also und
die hand die abstracts finden sie auch
schon drauf die kurzbeschreibungen
finden sie schon auf dem tagungsprogramm
einfach auf diese homepage ist noch eine
letzte kurze fragen müssen schluss
machen ja
die waschanlage auf
damit haben
das nächste spiel das thema bildung des
einen worden
oder
mehr
in dieser aufgabe sind
vereinbaren
nicht minder
sie werde aber auch der kirche
beziehungen
[Applaus]
also ich denke von den fragen wie gesagt
ist es der uns wieder so zu verlängern
das werde ich mich er will nur dass an
der stelle verdeutlichen wird ist das
ist ein sehr attraktives und das dass
man das theoretische aufbauen könnte
also dass er jetzt nicht um dinge geht
immer unsere welt und deswegen endlich
würde er diesen punkt wieder machen also
bei der frage nach ästhetischer freiheit
oder was auch immer ist diese
entscheidung mit terminiert und ich bin
nicht entscheidend weg zu sein wird
schon entscheidend sind schon vorher
passieren zu lassen
das ist auch eine spannende frage die
wir jedenfalls noch notieren können
diese frage betrifft eben noch die
kontext der wildnis freiheiten der
freiheit generell also die bindung an
die person an das objekt der freiheit
das sagt er sehr wenig dazu aber da
wollen wir ihn noch mehr befreien weil
er ist ja metaphysiker und damit hängt
ja alles mit allem zusammen siegen muss
er da auch eine antwort darauf haben
[Musik]
eines zu schreiben welche der sein
und jetzt muss ich einfach seine theorie
die hier sehr abstrakten generell
dargestellt ist auch bewähren anhand von
konkreten fragen und dazu haben wir dann
genug gelegenheit auf dem workshop in
der nächsten sitzung werden wir dann die
ergebnisse des workshops nach besprechen
vielleicht können wir auch den workshop
aufzeichnen vielleicht ist damit
einverstanden
vielleicht können wir auch teile davon
aufnehmen jedenfalls werden wir dann im
nächsten freitag die sitzung ausfallen
lassen müssen weil die tagung ist aber
da werden viele von ihnen daran
teilnehmen und dann sehen wir uns
jedenfalls in vollständiger anzahl hier
wieder in zwei wochen wo wir diesen
workshop um die tagung vielleicht auch
generell nach besprechen können dann
noch ein schönes wochenende und bis in
ein oder zwei wochen